Speaker 1: We're continuing our discussion around
gun violence that's been reignited due to the
recent mass shootings in Buffalo and Uvalde
and then a bunch of other mass shootings just
since those, too. But one of the talking points
you'll hear the most, I think you've all probably
heard this. Whenever a tragedy, a tragedy like
this happens is it's not guns that kill people.
It's people that kills people. And at a really
fundamental level. Okay, that's true. Right?
Guns don't fly around and shoot people. A person
has to pull the trigger. And oftentimes in every
mass shooting, it is someone who is deranged and
has horrible motivations. All of that I agree to.
But what you and I understand and why we see that
slogan or that talking point to be so harmful
is. The person who's already deranged has those
bad motivations, their ability to kill people.
And to kill a higher number of people comes
down to how effective of a killing tool,
a weapon they have to do that. And so at a
basic level, I think everyone understands this,
right? If I say you absolutely have to be
attacked, you have no choice. Someone's going
to attack you at your home. But you can decide
if it's going to be someone with just their bare
hands or someone with an AR 15. Everyone knows
they would choose the person with the bare hands.
So then. You understand then if someone's deranged
and they have psychotic ambitions to kill people,
but they can't get their hands on something that
does that act, killing so well, then they're not
going to be able to cause as much suffering,
as many deaths, as much carnage. So then,
without changing the hearts and minds of these
people, which we should all try to do, of course,
but without having to get into that
real complex topic, how do you prevent
someone from becoming so deranged? You are
limiting the amount of damage they can do.
So a great example of this is something
that happened in California a few days ago.
This happened at a hospital. Radio call went
out reporting a person armed with a knife at
the hospital. Officers determined that someone had
stabbed three hospital employees. SWAT officers
entered the hospital around 5:25 p.m.. The FBI was
at the scene and offering assistance where needed.
LAPD chief Michael Moore said around
530 that officers had cornered the
suspect alone in the area of the emergency
room at the Encino Hospital. We've locked
it down. We've isolate the individual,
he said. So a man goes into a hospital
trying to kill people. He stabs three people.
FBI corners him. Outcome no one dies. In Tulsa,
if you remember, a man went to a medical facility.
So these stories are very similar to men going
to medical facilities, trying to kill people.
One of them has an eye. One of them has a gun.
The one with the gun kills three people. The one
with the knife stabs three people and no one dies.
So you can see the point that I'm getting to
while of course it is a fault of the individuals,
it is the fault of those two men for trying
to kill people. All the blame is on them.
Their ability to actually enact the violence and
the suffering and the death that they were trying
to did come down to the type of weapon they had.
And so if we can prevent certain people like those
two guys from getting or at least the one who did
get the gun from getting such effective killing
tools, weapons that are designed to kill as many
people as possible, we're going to save lives
and we can do that. And why anyone standing in the
way of that, honestly, while I can tell you the
reasons I don't understand them. Like I don't
understand how appealing to a radical base or
appealing to NRA would possibly come above in your
mind, in your heart, protecting innocent people
from getting killed in cold blood. I mean, one of
the biggest things I'm confused about is watching
the way that certain Republican politicians are
acting about this issue. It's disturbing. But this
example shows while, yes, people kill people.
People's ability to kill a lot of people will
come down to if they can get their hands on a
UN, something that's designed to do that or not